okay so we've got this idea of bargain
and the bargain doesn't have to be a
good bargain it just has to be a real
bargain are you ready for a curve ball
this is a famous case from the beginning
of the 20th century the business of
canning Alaska's plentiful salmon was
new and promising companies would set up
factories and docks along the Alaska
Panhandle which at that time and still
today in some parts could only be
reached by ship did you know the Juneau
Alaska which is in the Panhandle cannot
be reached by car you either have to get
there by ship or by airplane even today
the season was very short just the
summer months during which time all the
fish would have to be caught processed
canned and the cans brought out by ship
usually to Seattle or San Francisco the
canneries would sign up crews in Seattle
or San Francisco to do the fishing and
work the machinery for a fixed rate for
the season paid on return to the city
the workers in this case were signed on
in San Francisco for $50 for the season
I told you this was at the beginning of
the 20th century and they got to Alaska
to the Alaska station and there they
refused to work unless the foreman
agreed to pay them $100 for the season
it was too late to get replacement and
because he didn't want to lose the whole
season the foreman agreed and signed new
contracts with each crew member at the
end of the season they get back in San
Francisco and the company refused to
honor the second contract and paid only
$50 the workers sued for the difference
what do you think happened there was a
bargain
wasn't there the name may not have been
a good bargain but it was a bargain